e aí
e pode chegar pode ficar a história vai
começar a
a hipótese pé
é isso e pode até dar uma voltinha
a hipótese até manda beijinho obrigada
obrigada pode sentar se acomodar
e aí
e ai que lindo a filha disse mas eu
conta histórias de livros infantis e
conta histórias de pessoas reais em
casamentos e empresas mas hoje eu queria
contar uma história diferente
e eu não quero contar uma história de
ficção nem uma história de outra pessoa
não hoje eu quero contar para vocês a
minha história
e vocês sabem o poder de uma história
e eu não sabia
e era uma vez uma menina que se chamava
marina marina significa aquela que veio
do mar mas eu não nasci na praia não eu
nasci em são paulo numa quarta-feira de
cinzas no meio de uma gente debaixo de
um temporal
e eu não tenho irmãos e meus amigos meus
primos moravam longe então companhias eu
tive que inventar para brincar
e eu brincava com as panelas da cozinha
com os gatos da vizinha e pegava uma
cornetinha amarela subir em cima de uma
mulher tinha e tocava tudo
é sim é isso mesmo eu subi em cima da
mureta da minha casa e fazia discursos
para ninguém
eu tinha ninguém escuta com o tempo a
coisa foi melhorado um pouquinho e eu
comecei até um público legal sabe quem
as toalhas no varal
e é verdade que elas não batiam palma
mas também não falava mal é
e eu comecei a estudar teatro porque eu
sonhava em ser atriz eu adoraria sentar
histórias personagens a minha mãe me
ajudava costurar os meus figurinos fazer
a maquiagem e cenografia estava sempre
na primeira fila aplaudindo tudo que eu
fazia
e já meu pai não tinha muito tempo tava
sempre trabalhando ele chegava do
trabalho e continuava trabalhando
se você já tentaram conversar com alguém
que está sempre atrás de uma tela
oi quem é que tá tentou um
e é difícil né pois é e eu tentava todos
os dias mas ela fica complicado eu
queria contar as minhas histórias para
ele contato que eu tinha feito na escola
mas ele tava sempre ali digitando do
computador não dava muita atenção porque
afinal de contas tinha muito trabalho e
eu insisti a insistir e ficava brigando
então chegou o momento que eu desisti
cresci me formei como atriz e um dia eu
tive que buscar uma outra maneira de me
comunicar
e com ele porque ele foi diagnosticado
com câncer no pulmão passou mais de 100
dias no hospital mais da metade
e na uti quem é que já tem um parente
internado na uti sabe como é geralmente
os hospitais deixou a gente visitar meia
hora tarde melhora a noite não mais que
isso
bom e quando o paciente está desacordado
em coma eles dizem que a gente conversar
com paciente mas é difícil
é porque você conversar por semanas por
alguém que
me responde não olha para você e você
nem sabe está te ouvindo eu conversava
ele tava aí todos os dias e conversava
tudo que eu podia mas chegou uma hora
que eu fiquei bem sem assunto
é isso né que assunto por tanto tempo de
alguém que não te respondi
é mas aí eu olhei para minha mãe
eu e a minha mãe tava todo dia ali atrás
dos médicos atrás de respostas para
saber como é que ele tava ela não
desistiria
e eu também não podia desistir né e eu
vi ela tão nervosa que eu fiquei
pensando que eu podia fazer para
deixá-la mais calma e também que tentar
ajudar meu pai
eu acho que tu podia fazer eu não sou
médica eu não sou psicóloga eu sou só
uma contadora de histórias é isso que eu
sei fazer é isso que eu faço a vida
inteira desde quando eu contava
histórias para ninguém
o ou quando a contar uma história suas
toalhas do varal então foi isso que eu
fiz eu me enchi de coragem
bom e comecei a contar todas as
histórias que eu conhecia ele cantava
todas as músicas eu gostava
e quando eu chegava na uti ficar um
clima de poesia as enfermeiras abriu um
sorrisão e dizia olha chegou a contadora
de histórias às vezes os parentes dos
outros pacientes que não tavam junto
comigo era tão bonita mas com meu pai
nada acontecia ele não reagia então
entendi que eu tava sendo egoísta e eu
tava fazendo mais bem para mim do que
para ele porque afinal de contas agora
eu tinha ganhado um motivo para viver eu
passava os meus dias escolhendo músicas
e histórias para contar e cantar para
ele e ele nada não melhoraram nada
bom então achei melhor parar
e quando eu parei meu pai piorou muito
muito muito muito quase morreu na minha
frente
e nesse momento eu lembrei que o amigo
deles infância tinha falado para eu
cantar hábitos eu adoro hábitos mas sei
lá eu acho tava querendo isso não era
muito bom eu ficava com vergonha de
cantar ai não cantava naquele momento
que vi meu pai quase indo embora
e eu pensei
olá tudo bem que eu não falo inglês bem
tudo bem que eu não vou cantar direito e
eu tenho que fazer
e eu fiz eu respirei fundo me enche de
coragem
o e cantei
e quando eu cantei fi canta são
o ri canta são os olhos do meu pai se
abrir
e quando cantei wanna hold you wanna
hold you a mão do meu pai se mexeu bem
devagarzinho procurando a minha mão
e quando eu cantei oh my love to you i
love you i love you would do meu pai
tudo bem devagarzinho
tô pedindo um abraço
nós nos abraçamos
o meu pai acordou do coma com músicas e
histórias e se as histórias são capazes
de acordar alguém do coma imagina pelas
podem fazer por alguém acordado
e quando isso aconteceu eu já contava
histórias às sete anos deve ser contado
história montam divulgar em outros
países em festivais em empresas escolas
até na tv mas de verdade eu achava que o
que eu fazia era mero entretenimento só
um momento divertido no dia da pessoa é
só que eu vou vir aqui cantar contar uma
história fazer público sorrir um pouco
esquecer dos problemas eu achava que era
só isso que já seria bastante coisa mas
não é só isso só
e quando aconteceu isso com meu pai eu
entendi o poder
o que tem uma história assis coração
poderosas porque elas podem fazer alguém
te tentar elas podem conectar corações
une famílias podem fazer com alguém
dentro de uma empresa sinto orgulho de
pertencimento elas podem ajudar alguém a
aprender a ler
é porque as histórias emocionam há um
tempo atrás o recebeu uma mensagem de
uma professora que tinha aluno de 10
anos que estava com dificuldades de
aprender a ler e escrever quem é
professor sabe que com 10 anos
normalmente as crianças já sabem ler e
escrever mas aquelas crianças muita
dificuldade então ela mostrou para eles
alguns vídeos no meu canal no youtube
onde eu contava umas histórias infantis
e cria um projeto onde essas crianças
reconta vão essas mesmas histórias para
as crianças menores da escola
ah e assim ela se interessar em ler
melhoraram muito na escrita então
professora me mandou uma mensagem
pedindo meu endereço me mandou 20
cartinhas escritas pelas crianças
oi e o projeto essa professora ganhou um
prêmio ficou em segundo lugar no pra ler
o que é um problema de incentivo
nacional a leitura
é mas não fui eu que fiz isso
e no meu computador de história você
poderoso suas histórias
é a história que eu contei para o meu
pai foi história certa porque a história
que emocionada o coração dele a história
que essa professora mostrou os alunos
foi história certa porque incentivou
eles aprender a ler ea escrever as
histórias são poderosas porque as
histórias transformam o mundo mas o que
é o mundo o mundo somos nós
bom então conte histórias seja histórias
bom obrigado
e aí
o lugar é